i do want to welcome you to ask doc
live now there's a little disclaimer
that i have to read
that says that the content of this
program is to provide
educational information only in the
importance of nutrition
and supplementation in a world where the
food supply
is empty and void of vitamins and
especially minerals
needed these things are needed not just
to survive but to thrive
and that's something that we can do pain
and dis-ease
is not a requirement of growing older
and i absolutely love that
in fact as i'm growing older i'm feeling
better
and better now this program is not meant
to take the place of your primary care
physician
and the fda requires us to let you know
that our products are not meant to treat
prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases
now diseases are too commonly classified
as being genetic the only thing that
you're inheriting
for the most part is your way of eating
folks
and this has been proven by the science
of epigenetics
and i think that it is just
such an honor such an honor to be able
to have one of the
founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us every friday as we are going
through and addressing the body
as a whole now folks this is coming
from research of his very very own
where he had a passion well one he
overcame a lot as a child and
something that's going on so commonly
today with our children
he is proof that great people come
in all different shapes and sizes and it
doesn't
matter if there is a desire
there is a way to
make great things out of life now
without further ado
i am honored to be able to welcome
dr joel wallach dr wallach
thank you so much for being here with us
and good
morning to you well thank you so much
rebecca and thank you and your entire
team
you know i i look at uh our friday
morning group as a family here so i
appreciate
all the good things that everybody does
and
um you know you've heard me talking for
many years now
and um i've always been kind of groping
around looking for bits and pieces of
information to fill up the little
blank holes that people ask questions
about and i didn't have answers for
well just a couple of days ago
a lot of what i was groping around with
was quantified by lsu louisiana state
university they came up with a big
multi-million dollar grant
and they put this all out and
they're on fox news early in the morning
and
i had a zoom to do so i grabbed all the
headlines
and then after the zoom i went back to
get the details and
to study and all that kind of stuff and
they'd already pulled it down in an hour
they'd pulled it down
fox news had stuff on there about a kid
with a blister on his toe for three days
why did they pull this one down in just
an hour
okay when you hear the results of this
it'll blow your mind
now um
this was a study it was done by lsu okay
10 years multi-million dollar study and
they were looking
at um the world's river deltas
where all the big rivers go to the ocean
or the gulfs or the
seas and everything and they call them
deltas because it kind of
looks like a fan when the river goes out
there
and the silt and the mud and everything
like that build up in those areas
and enrich with minerals you know from
the
erosion and so this is where all the
fish and the shellfish and
so forth went there to have babies okay
so the world's river deltas were known
as the home to seafood
nurseries for shrimp and crabs and like
fish and that kind of stuff 300 million
people around the world
depend on the deltas for their
livelihoods
okay 300 million people live around
these river deltas from the continents
and the big islands and
stuff like that okay well
over time these deltas have been sinking
okay and shrinking and this is from nasa
from the satellites and everything
they're looking and they're measuring
everything so this is
very well documented and
um the erosion now we're going to talk
just about the usa
this is the scary part the usa um
erosion and sinking land and
the the rise of the carbon dioxide
and put this in quotes from climate
change
unquote have killed okay
the um
the louisiana uh woods
and wetlands in louisiana
killed 40 percent of the usa's wetlands
okay which were found in louisiana okay
40 are now dead okay
two thousand square miles in louisiana
alone
since the nineteen thirties have died
eighty thousand eighty percent of the
usa wetlands
losses from the mississippi river delta
okay and um
here it comes i have to i have to hold
my breath when i say this
the amount of silt that has been
withheld from the ocean just in the usa
just in the usa each year is 150 million
tons
of silt and sediment has been blocked up
by the hydroelectric dams in the usa per
year 150 million tons per year
that is shocking that's a gob
that's more than some islands way right
okay
okay and so
um uh then um
hydroelectric plants okay make up 38
of the dams in the rivers united states
hoover dam came on in 1936
was the world's largest concrete
structure and also the largest electric
generating
facility then came uh the grand coulee
dam
and then tv a tennessee valley authority
i can remember as a kid
growing up in a farm in missouri there
everybody's clapping and yelling yay
about the
tva thing going on and then of course
the three gorges dam in um
hubei china now
now in the world let's kind of look in
the world here that's even scarier
the first hydroelectric plant
was in grand rapids michigan in 1880 two
years before 1882 and thomas edison
pulled the switch on the first
commercial electric during plants
in new york okay and it was to
run machinery for a furniture
manufacturing company called the
wolverine chair factory
1880 okay and of course
all this is documented in my cd uh in
um 2003 hell's kitchen
in 2005 the book hell's kitchen goes
into the history of all these
hydroelectric dams and everything
and how they cut off the food supply to
the rivers and to the lakes and
to the to the farmland and so forth and
the um uh the ocean cut off the food of
the ocean
and that's why that's why the carbon
dioxide is going up the carbon dioxide
is not going up because
of fossil fuels it was always a big lie
the fossil fuels didn't do that okay
what happened here was
when you cut off the food supply to the
ocean three-fifths of the world's plant
life is in the ocean you've heard me say
this before
three-fifths of the world's plant mass
on earth is in the ocean and when the
silt would go in and feed the algae and
the plankton the seaweed and all that
kind of stuff
they would gobble up all the carbon
dioxide to make amino acids
carbon chains carbohydrates sugars
fiber everything they do but when they
dammed up these rivers
it cut off the food supply to these
allergies not enough to kill them just
like when you get arthritis it's a
nutritional deficiencies when you have
diabetes there's nutritional
deficiencies
you don't die right away you suffer for
years
but you're still kind of clanking along
on four cylinders out of six
well the same thing is true here with
the ocean i looked up and sure enough i
found
the phd thesises of two
um marine biologists who are studying
the nutrition of seaweed
and they require 17 minerals to be able
to take carbon dioxide out of the air
and make carbon chains out of it
now if any one of those 17 those
minerals away
you take the algae that they require
the algae cannot do its job
yeah i mean so dr well like i i'm
thinking about this and i remember
science in
elementary school when we were looking
at plants
and their purpose and what they needed
and you take those things away and
plants die i mean that's
elementary elementary school yeah yeah
now let's let's even get scarier
everybody knows the great barrier reef
off the west coast of queensland
australia is dying
they're blaming it on fossil fuels well
it turns out in 1927
three major hydroelectric dams were
built on
the three rivers that feed the great
barrier reef
in queensland and so since 1927
the food supply has been diminished
diminished diminished and cut off
okay to the great barrier reef and
that's why the great barrier reef is
dying not because of fossil fuels
because they cut off the silt and again
i said okay where did that silt come
from all of the mountains in queensland
were mountains that were formed by
volcanic eruptions they're all full of
volcanic ash and minerals
and that's what was feeding the great
barrier reef for millions of years
they damned it up and and then in 70
years they've killed something that's
been there for
millions of years only human beings have
the power to do such stupid things
okay and so this makes our
supplementation even
more important now here here comes here
comes the coup de grace you know what
the coup de grace is
okay okay coup de gras is a french word
for
let's say you're in a sword fight okay
and um
because somebody challenged somebody and
you're mortally wound in your suffering
the guy comes up and he says okay i'm
going to give you a coup de grace
poom he shoots you in the head and kills
you instantly so you're not going to
suffer for a day before you die
that's called a coup de grace doing them
a favor you're doing a favor by ending
it quickly okay
so the coup de gras here for the for the
world
is um now there's going
to be right now they're in the process
of making 3 500 new dams new
hydroelectric dams
are being built right now in the world 3
500 more hydroelectric dams are being
built
nobody's making any um
i want you to say adaption to put augers
through the dam under the dam around the
dam over the dam to get this silt around
to feed the ocean
and so this is why it's so important for
everybody who wants to add 25 to 50
healthful years of their life
everybody who has to add 25 to 50
healthy years of life to their families
they had better be taken to 215
nutrients i used to say the 90th century
nutrients
that's our healthy start pack which is
the core of our healthy brain and heart
pack
well we added 115 nutrients to the
healthy start pack and our healthy brain
and heart pack has 215 nutrients in it
okay now let's look at some details here
if i may for just a few more minutes
our government came out oh now by
supplementation
and 12 federal lawsuits i've been able
to eliminate
two diseases that were said to be
genetic cystic fibrosis i was
found the first non-human case of cystic
processes they fired me for saying it
wasn't genetic
from the yerkes primate center i was
working for nasa as a pathologist
said well like you're out of your mind
that is the classic example of a
genetically transmitted disease you're
fired
i said well can't i prove to you no
you're out of here you're too crazy
okay so that's when i became an atrial
physician and then
um in 2011 we gave jerry lewis
uh from the from the um um must recipe
association right in his telethon every
year
here in 20 years jerry lewis raised
two billion dollars
okay for the muscular dystrophy
association two billion dollars he
raised for them in those telethons
and uh marvin rob one of our navy seals
who's one of our great distributors with
youngevity
uh he and i were working in
um utah indiana and
eastern canada on these colonies of
peoples that have a certain diet
and they had the highest rate of
mustardicity of any
communities in the world so we're
treating these kids and curing them
so we gave jerry lewis 12 of our charts
including one guy who was born with
obviously and
31 years old when we met him and in just
six months time we had cured him of his
mustard history
okay and so we gave jerry lewis 12 of
these things and he contacted the
doctors
jerry lewis personally contacted the
doctor who signed off on those charts
the j that um marvin rob had personally
delivered to him
our navy seal guy and um he checked with
the doctors and he's just flabbergasted
these doctors signed up so we don't know
why but you know wallach's program
has eliminated most justifying these
kids
so he took it to the muscular dystrophy
association in 2011
and guess what before he turned around
and walked out the door
they fired jerry lewis that ended the
telethon everybody said whatever
happened to the telethon whatever
happened to jerry lewis
well that's because they fired him okay
and they went under the next year
without jerry lewis in the telethon the
massachusetts association went under
now here it comes april 16 2013
was our 12th federal lawsuit in federal
court
we prevailed we won and that lawsuit
was to force the manufacturers of
infamil similac and all these baby milk
replacers
and food formulas to put these minerals
in there
particularly one or two minerals which
were the deficiency of which was the
cause of musculus
and cystic fibrosis and sediment death
syndrome
okay so dr milan and i had gone to
china in 1988
we had done 1 700 autopsies
on kids there it was published in 1990
in three languages mandarin cantonese
and english
in the biology of trade gentleman
research 1
700 autopsies on kids under the age of
10 that had died of cardiomyopathy heart
disease
okay and 35 percent had cystic fibrosis
100 had muscular dystrophy and over 100
of them would have been diagnosed with
uh sediment death syndrome in the united
states under one year of age okay
and so you know we got that published
we won in federal court so we published
it as an article
i spoke about it almost every day for
months
remember talking 2013 and
a year and a half later september 13
2014 front page
on the um uh let's see
charlotte observer which is the big
newspaper from charlotte north carolina
kind of like new york times for new york
big headlines i mean we're talking
bold big you know inch high letters and
numbers just like
third world war stuff okay we don't know
why but sentiment destined rome has
vanished in the state of north carolina
three months later the saint louis post
dispatch and all the newspapers in
missouri we don't know why but suddenly
death syndrome has vanished in the state
of missouri
then three months later every newspaper
in the world came out and said we know
why but the diagnosis of sentiment death
syndrome
has dropped dramatically by 85 to 95
percent and then it was quantified
they said before 2011 the number of
sentiment death syndrome deaths were
one per 300 normal births and
today it is one in 3 000
births okay because we had put those
nutrients in the baby
formulas so there's a lot of things we
don't want to vanish but
disease and stuff like that dr wallach
vanish is a very good word
vanish is a good word and so okay here
we come
okay now we're at a point where we have
this
this huge problem where we've
you know there's no way you can eat well
enough it's like say here you're talking
about the car at the beginning
okay of this
event here and
would you put dirt from texas or
oklahoma in your car rather than
you know high quality oil to save a few
bucks not even
a jeep no come on rebecca i mean
this is soil from texas and oklahoma
there's bound to be some oil in it
okay you get my story yeah it's like
that's what doctors are telling that's
what doctors are telling you to do
for your body don't put oil in your car
put dirt from texas in your car
don't take vitamins and minerals just
eat well you're going to get everything
you need
yet the dams are cutting off the food
supply to the plants we used to
supply these nutrients because we're
putting wood ashes which is our source
of minerals
into these gardens
so dr wylik this word
mm-hmm that's found in so many different
um it's spelled on the boxes of so many
different
foods well you know with two or three
different vitamins
well conceptually it's good but it's
kind of anemic you know two when you
need
when you need 215 now they're just
giving you two
um you know again that's like saying
um i'm just going to put dirt in my car
and because it's remote from oklahoma or
texas now here
here's one um the first fortification of
food
okay was milk um right after the first
world war
just about every kid in america had
rickets okay because of all the
factories and the smoke cutting off
the sun and kids were in school they
were going to babysitters and stuff like
that when the parents are working in the
factories and going to war
soldiers and so there were no kids
out there in the gardens in the fields
without shirts out in the sun
they're all in classrooms now okay
and so some clever guy i don't even know
the guy's name i had to look it up and
find out who it was
said we need to put vitamin d3 in milk
and so when they put vitamin d3 in milk
it ended the plague
the pandemic okay of rickets in the
united states
by fortifying milk by adding vitamin d3
to it and so that's why you see on these
cartons paper cartons of milk or the
bottles of milk
says fortified with vitamin d3 that goes
way back to the first world war
so i mean even back then
they started realizing the importance of
nutrients
but see you have to appreciate there was
one guy and one nutrient
and our body needs a whole lot more we
need 215.
okay
john had mentioned that there's over a
million dams worldwide
and and keep that silt which is full of
minerals
from carrying on the way it was designed
that's keeping those minerals from going
into the food as it
was designed and
it's affecting all of us yeah that's why
the ocean is dying because we cut off
we cut out only human beings have the
capacity to shut off the food supply to
the oceans
by damming up the rivers for electricity
you know for
to to run factories and stuff like that
okay
now there's nothing wrong with that but
they should have compensated by saying
look everybody we're going to give you a
discount tax deductions for taking
vitamins and minerals
but no what did they do they gave
everybody health insurance
now the doctors are happy now we can
send our kids to college because
we have health insurance and we don't
have to feel bad about building these
people for a hundred thousand dollars to
a bone marrow transplant and really all
they need to be is gluten-free and take
vitamins and minerals
you know we'll bill them a hundred
thousand dollars for a bone marrow
transplant
we can send our kids to college now with
that money and
everybody's happy because health
insurance pays for their surgery so i
don't feel guilty and charge them a
hundred thousand dollars
health insurance was the worst possible
thing for human health
because it gave doctors justification
for treating the symptoms
as opposed to getting rid of the problem
well and i've heard that that bone
marrow transplant is a very painful
painful situation that i was
see that well that happens because
people aren't getting the nutrition to
keep their bone marrow size
cells giving their bone marrow cells
alive okay
and so when their bone marrow cells die
is filled up with scar tissue
and uh fat and it's called bone marrow
dysplasia
and for a while they'll give you iron
shot in b12 shot you know
every week for a couple of months or a
year or so and after a while you get
tired of it and
and the benefit is going away because
those cells are dying
and the reason why they had to give you
a shot of b12 and iron
is because you couldn't absorb the b12
and iron because your intestines are
dead for eating gluten for 20 30 40 50
years
that's why we added more folic acid our
methylfolate to the
btt 2.5 okay because folic acid is also
required to make red blood cells
and hemoglobin in the bone marrow so
we're trying to help people as much as
we can
okay there was folic acid in there but
now we have 400 times more i mean we
really put a lot in there
okay and so um these are the reason why
we do this stuff
to try and compensate for all those
silly things that everybody else is
doing out there
um and not paying attention to the basic
root cause of the problem
so um the greatest gift you can give to
somebody
is this a book in the cd hell's kitchen
because it goes through the history of
all this and see the progression and how
all this
works and and so forth uh don't forget
the book
um black gene lies and cd black sheen
lies don't forget immortality goes into
all the things that along the people's
avoid
and all the things that people lonely
people do okay
and here is the result okay here is
quantified results um
it came out just a couple of months ago
again
that the human life expectancy is 155
they're talking about the average human
life expectancy is 155.
the longest of people live to be 160 is
200 that kind of stuff
we'll get into that in a minute but the
the
agreed upon human life expectancy is
155.
right now we've dropped four years
we've dropped um four years okay
because of the pandemic thing and so we
went from
79 average lifespan in america and
leaving 76 years on the table
79 minus 155 is 76 we left on the table
now we're leaving 80 years on the table
medical doctors who
work in the emergency rooms and
hospitals their average lifespan
according to cdc's 57
rebecca 57 and so you subtract that from
medical doctors working in emergency
rooms and hospitals according to cdc are
leaving 98 years on the table
okay so why would you listen to them
medical doctor is the worst person to
ask about longevity
now if you've been run over by a truck
and you're bleeding you've got to go to
the emergency room
when it comes to asking them about long
life and health don't ask your doctor
ask your veterinarian i used to tell
people before i became a physician i
said i'm going to treat you like
a dog but you're going to get better
everybody thought i was kidding but i
was
telling the truth okay black americans
regardless whether they're from africa
or the islands or wherever they're from
uh their average is 72 subtract that
from 155.
they're leaving 83 years on the table
latinos in america they do better
their average lifespan is 81.8 they're
leaving 73.2 years on the table
and then um let's look at the japanese
their average lifespan is 84. they're
leaving 71 years on the table
let's look at the filipinos their
average lifespan is 69.6
and i did a zoom for them last night and
shared this with them freaked them out
the average lifespan of 69.6 subtracted
from 155 they're leaving
85.4 years on the table um
australians our average lifespan is 83
they're live 72 years on the table
india's average lifespan is 70 they're
leaving 85 years on the table
uh this is the scary one oh well vietnam
is doing pretty good
their average lifespan of 76 are leaving
um
let's see 79 years on the table russia
uh the ravaged lifespan is 70 they're
leaving 83 years on the table
okay now hunza was a very primitive
population near the
um you can see here the guilt our
glacier between
pakistan and china their average
lifespan is 120.
documented everybody in the world agrees
upon that
their longest lived documented people
are in their 160s 160 568.
that's because of all these minerals the
guilt our glacier you subtract 120 from
155 they're only leaving 35 years on the
table
but the ones who live to be 160 they're
doing good because they're beating it by
five years
okay so we need to do more of what the
honda cuts are doing
and less of what people are doing like
in india
their average lifespan of 70 they're
leaving 85 years on the table
and like i said this many many times
over the last year and a half
india just went over 400 000 dead
okay so there's we're at um
we're at 620 000.
okay and so um back
in 1918 during the spanish flu
in 1919 the spanish flu those two years
we lost 657 000 dead right now or 620
000 dead before the end of this year we
will beat the spanish flu
which is the worst pandemic in world's
history until now we're going to beat
that okay
we're already at 6 20. we've got six
months left to go
okay then the other thing we have to
look at here
is the
from india and the spanish flu in six
months time they lost 20 million dead
six months time 20 million dead the
rivers were being dammed up
there wasn't any way they could even
burn enough bodies in the streets and so
they're just throwing all the bodies in
the rivers and damning up the rivers
with all these
corpses and causing all flooding all
through india
that's horrible yeah and so then in that
same six months they had 110 million
cases
our worst day was 97 000 dead in one day
1919 okay from the spanish flu
now here it comes i said okay since
india had such the worst
case scenario during the spanish flu
what
what what's going on with india so i
went to the world
health organization database and i spent
two months digging around
in there okay through computers
what i found was this india has 29
states
and seven territories the northern nine
states have ninety-five percent of the
deaths
from the spanish flu and also currently
now from the coven-19
and this new delta variant the worst
variant
five times is more infectious and double
the deadliness is from india
all 50 states now have this delta
variant rumbling around through it all
50 states now have reported it
okay well back then
india 95 of the deaths occurred in the
northern
nine states and 87 percent
yeah 87 of the infections occurred in
the nine northern states southern 20
states and seven territories only had
five percent of the deaths
and only thirteen percent of the
infections so i
asked the world health organization
database okay
do they all eat the same way and said no
the northern nine states live on wheat
barley ran oates because uh the uk
england had been there for a hundred
years occupying
northern india and that's how they were
getting all these people from india into
their military to go
occupy every other country in the world
using all these people you always see
these people
from india and in the british military
okay
and so they taught them how to grow
wheat
and eat wheat and grow wheat and eat
wheat and grow wheat and drink wheat
okay beer and whiskey and all kind of
stuff
whereas the southern
uh 20 states and seven territories are
swampy
places and so they grow rice
and they live on rice like asians and
that's why they have such few
so few infections and deaths there are
homogeneous people they all belong to
the same religion
1.7 billion people they all belong to
the same religion they're all the same
people it's not like us we have you know
people from you know probably 100
different countries here okay and i
don't know how many different religions
and
races and all that kind of stuff but
india is very homogenous and so it's how
they were eating made the difference
and that's what's making a difference
today in india if you live in the
northern united states you are messed up
you are in trouble
you live in the southern 20 states and
seven territories and um
you know people brag about how well
india does well those are they're only
doing well in the southern states
they're not doing well in the northern
states
okay and they're cut they're going to
catch up they're going to pass us in the
number
we were number one the number of deaths
of all the countries in the world
uh india is going to pass this so in
this next couple of months
again so dr welling
when we're looking at everything that's
going on with the pandemic
and i mean i i'd like to look beyond the
pandemic
and look at the rise in things
that are con that are contributed by
blood sugar
things that are contributed by um heart
disease i mean all those things are on
the rise as well
yeah we already know the answer to that
well i know you and i know the answer to
it
and it's actually pretty simple it's
just a matter of
how much do you value
yourself and your health
well you're responsible for everything
for yourself and your family
and so again you got to get rid of the
bad stuff to maximize absorption no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat bread around those
no sugar no carbonated drinks
there are no um genetically transmitted
diseases there are no genetically
transmitted birth defects
there are no there are no autoimmune
diseases doctors invented those terms
because they didn't know the answers to
those things they're all nutritional
deficiencies caused by electricity
and damming up the rivers okay no wood
ashes for the gardens
and they never wanted to say you know we
have no earthly idea what it is
and so they blamed it on your genes and
your body attacking itself so they
wouldn't have to take responsibility
they could justify treating you for
something for 40 50 years
you can get rid of it in two weeks with
a supplement okay
well those days are over because we're
getting the truth out there
and so that's why we have the kids toddy
it's a liquid
okay this is one of the greatest things
we ever came up with
a kid's toddy kids love it it tastes
good
it has 90 essential nutrients in it
except for the efas which you have to
take the ebay separately
and then of course we have the cal toddy
it has calcium
vitamin d3 and 78 minerals in it
and so for kids okay they need to get
off all the bad stuff
make them eat like an asian have to eat
corn and rice and sweet potatoes with
butter out they'll love it
okay kids toddy cal toddy kids sprinkles
instead of girl scout cookies and boy
scout cookies all that gluten in it
we need to get the girl scouts and the
boy scouts to be selling
kids kids sprinkles vitamins and
minerals
and i put this on my gluten-free vanilla
ice cream every night at dinner time and
i also put on my
gluten-free um green tea ice cream
okay put there's 30 little packets in
this box
okay and this is what we need to get the
girl scouts and boy scouts working on
the kids sprinkles instead of gluten all
those cookies
okay killing people they do taste really
good i'd never thought about
sprinkling it on vanilla ice cream
yeah that's awesome dr wallace thank you
for the tip
yeah and so and then of course rebound
has
75 actually 78 but i just say for easy
math 75 minerals
and 25 vitamins amino acids are rebound
oops things all over the place here our
rebound
okay we have in the cans and then we
also have it in these sticks
uh 30 of these individual servings in a
box
i take the little sticks with me on the
airplanes because they're light and i
put three or four in my pocket the cans
i have them buy them for me to my
location where i'm going but i also
drink them at home in the cans because
real convenient to pop the top and
and drink the the rebound which is made
for
our friend through ratliff you know he
is a great uh professional basketball
player 24 years old who
was playing with a atlanta hawks and he
had bone bone arthritis in his knees
he's only 24 years old
the carly's popped off his right hip and
he fractured his right wrist
and his shooting arm and they took his
contract away from him and we invented
the healthy bone and joint pack for him
and we invented the rebound for him
that's why his pictures
on there okay and he has every athlete
in the world just about using our
rebound
and um three months later he gets his
contract back for 35 million dollars
then he plays for 11 more years and
makes another 100 million dollars so he
made a total
after we rebuilt him with the healthy
bone and joint pack and the rebound
which he takes still every day even
though he's retired
um and he has a big big community of
kids
three thousand kids in a community
project
okay in his hometown which he provides
all these
products for okay um
i i get breathless and this is what we
have to do get the boy scouts involved
get the girl scouts involved they were
the ones who saved america after
after the uh first world war was over
after the second world war
over we enlisted the scouts to go out
and knock on doors make sure everybody
had food
we weeded their gardens for them emptied
the ashes out of their stoves and
that kind of stuff um washed their car
we babysat for them we did all these
kind of things
and so boy scouts have 135
merit badges i had 32 of them
okay and by the time i graduated school
at age 18 as a boy scout with 32 merit
badges
order the arrow eagle scout okay i
i had a college education the equivalent
of education of a college education by
the time i graduated school at age 18.
okay high school and then same way with
the girl scouts they have over 200
service pins which are their equivalent
of the of the um
merit badges and boy scouts and i know
they're having a big hoo-ha between the
girl scouts and boy scouts right now
but we want to engage them and get them
involved in saving america
stop all this infighting and let's get
together and save america
um for the girl scouts i'm for the boy
scouts i'm for the brownies
and the daisies i'm for the cub scouts
i didn't realize this but you can be a
cub scout and a brownie
in kindergarten even at that age at six
years of age you can be eligible for the
cub scouts and the brownies
so let's get them going here and save
america
yes let's do it let's do it and
you know dr wellick i love the fact that
we have the technology that we do now
because we are being able to reach
so many more people um
with our meetings i mean here we have
almost 80 people with us here right now
and this video is going to be seen by
thousands and thousands
yeah because you post it and people who
are at work or something like that are
just waking up they'll get on it later
absolutely
yeah can't thank you enough so i
i love the fact that we have this option
to share this information
and folks health really is
simple you have to make a choice
though at how important it is to you
and sometimes you don't realize
your importance you put everybody else
in front of you
but if something happens to you who's
going to take care of them
and that's that's something that i
really have a heart for because i work
with a lot of people that are caregivers
whether it's to children with special
needs
or to aging parents
all of us need this nutrition
and especially those that are caring for
other people
you have to take care of yourself you
have to invest
in yourself so that you can continue to
be
not just the best you
i get better and better now
you said something there rebecca i'm
going to stop here for a minute
he said invest in yourself yeah
we have this little book that was
designed for kids it's called wallach
street for kids i always call it by the
shark version wall street for kids it
was wallace street for kids okay
and it teaches them how to make their
youngevity business
a not only a willable business but also
a business by which they can get tax
benefits
so you have to make a business plan and
this book teaches you know
a cub scout or a brownie how to make
a um a business plan
so that their supplements are paid for
by their young duty business and their
tax deductible because it's part of the
business plan well
uh and your health insurance is paid for
by your young duty business is tax
deductible
you get to deduct your
any medical care as tax deductible and
then also
the square footage you use in your house
for warehouse for your office
for your conference room or
um studio whatever you have we use about
of our house okay for youngevity
between all the warehouse and studio and
office and all kinds of stuff
and so let's just say your mortgage is
two thousand dollars your rent is two
thousand dollars whatever it is
and you're using 25 percent that's 500
bucks but you also get to take 25
percent off your utilities your
homeowner's insurance
the people you have to come in to clean
the house all kind of stuff
that's 25 so now you're up around
a thousand bucks deductions every that's
twelve thousand dollars in tax
deductions you get every year
just for a fifty dollar cost to keep
your franchise every year
fifty bucks a year which is tax
deductible and each year
when you initially sign up and each year
when you renew
i give you 500 bucks free worth 500
bucks free
500 bucks free worth of
business information and business
building techniques and everything okay
plus a new website all for free every
year when you renew
and also when you start and so just the
tax benefits this the tax benefits
can can save you 10 12 15
20 000 a year just the tax benefits
including you know all the health stuff
you get to be deducted because in your
in your business plan it says
that your young jewish business is
responsible for taking care of your
health needs as part of your benefits
you get for running the business
okay and how you do that it's all in
this book wallace street aka wall street
for kids
okay so everybody i mean if you give
that book along with hell's kitchen the
book
and um epigenetics the book and
immortality of the book
uh you're going to be adding 25 to 50
healthful years of people's lives
i i get breathless when i think about
that
yeah it's pretty incredible folks i mean
it's
and it's something that's that's needed
it's there's purpose
in this so if you're looking for
something to give you
more purpose in life something that you
can be proud of doing
as you're helping others find and obtain
better health you're in the right place
right now
we do have a call team well one get back
with the person invited you to this
program
okay that's most important for those of
you who were not invited
to um this watch this video by anybody
specific
we do have a call team that's available
at 855-949-7234
and you know i love it dr wallach that
we also now have a
certified holistic health coach course
that is available not just for
distributors
but also for the general population
where they can get
information we have taken all of your
research
your publications teaching
on the four areas of health
and how all the nutrients are so
important
in them and then also the solution not
many
programs have that where they teach a
solution
and we teach the solution as well and
for those who want to
build a business with it we teach you
how to build a business as well
and if you're interested in that we have
a special number for that and that's
855-949-3377
again that is for the certified holistic
health coach
program if you are interested in that as
just general population as a consumer as
a distributor
that's available for you so there is a
little fee to it but i'll tell you what
for a hundred bucks a year
it beats some of the programs that i've
gone to that cost me thousands
and they prevented me from being able to
offer solutions
so that's that's the new a unique thing
about our program
that's offered by the institute of
holistic health
dr wallach we have so many hands up
right now let's go ahead
and get started yeah those with hands so
the first hand that we have
up is captain sam captain sam
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr
wallach hey hello doctor once again i
want to say thank you sir
thank you to serve with you i've been
seeing you since the 1960s
okay and uh it's an honor to serve with
you sir
so i have with services oh my god yeah
no always always
i have a friend of mine she's a retired
teacher
she's already starting the protocols and
she has two
questions for you her name is barbara go
ahead barbara say hello and ask your
questions
good morning dr wallick it's nice good
morning
barbara is the full name okay go ahead
all right we can't take too long two
things i have a very good friend who's
and is suffering from ataxia he's losing
his balance
uh his speech gets slurred sometimes and
he said it's hereditary and his family
is there anything nutrition that he can
okay
a couple of questions here how old is
you said he's 67 how much does he weigh
uh probably 150.
okay does he have gray hair yes very
okay and does he have varicose veins or
spider veins in his legs
no okay or does he have any skin issues
any eczema dermatitis
or rosacea does he ever complain about
ringing is there's any tinnitus or
wringing or buzzing
no but he does he does have his
dizziness stuff and he falls
he yeah yeah that's balance that's a
taxi okay does he have any bowel
problems
uh down syndrome ibs
celiac disease okay
well he's got osteoporosis of the skull
as his problem squeezing the auditory
branch and also the vestibular branch of
the eighth cranial nerves
okay and so when you see when you have
white gray or silver hair that's a
deficiency that's not a factor of aging
it's a deficiency
that same deficiency that causes gray
hair and varicose veins and hemorrhoids
also causes ruptured aneurysms in the
brain and the aorta
michael jackson died at age 51 of a
ruptured aneurysm
in the brain and he had vitiligo when he
was 10
12 years old by the time he was 15 his
skin was snow white like typing paper
had white hair had to wear gloves with
jewels on him everybody thought that was
just
you know his being an entertainer but he
wore the gloves because it scared
everybody to see a black guy with white
hands
okay okay so here we go 150 pounds
he needs to get rid of all the bad stuff
so he can absorb no fried foods no
processed
meats no oils no glutens no we've no
brother in oats no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet one's got to go
this is a lifetime deal this is not just
for two weeks he's gonna eat that way
for a lifetime
then he needs to take two healthy brain
and heart packs for months
two healthy brain and heart pattern
about to full roast everything twice a
day
he needs to take three of our msm
tablets three times a day it'll be two
bottles a month of
msm three at breakfast three at lunch
street dinner time and they're designed
to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
your bone itself
and then he also needs to take um the
vitamin d three three of those twice a
day two bowels a month
and lastly i would throw in the
um let's see here i would throw in our
cal
our cal toddy it's got calcium and
vitamin d3 and collagen in it but it
also has our 78 minerals in it
plant-derived minerals
i'm going to take an ounce of that twice
a day there's two parts a month
and then call us every couple of weeks
because you are going to have a great
testimony with this guy
this is so common but this is how she
approached the skull and i actually
wrote a book there's 25 different
diseases you get
including atoxia balance problems
okay there's 25 different diseases you
can get from osteoporosis
it's called it's all in your head this
is the book it's all in your head
you need to get that book doctors never
talk about osteoporosis it's called
they want you to think you got
parkinson's disease or als or lou
gehrig's disease
okay because they get to treat you for
40 years that way
as opposed to treating you for just a
couple of weeks and getting rid of the
problem
so you need to get a hold of this book
it's all in your head
and share it with everybody and the best
christmas gift you can give everybody
the best
birthday gifts the best graduation gifts
anytime somebody requires
a gift give them the book it's all in
your head because you'll add 25 years to
their life okay
okay now i have a second question about
myself
to be very breathing okay because i know
a lot of people are waiting go
uh i got hit by a car when i was walking
across the street as a pedestrian
i had a knife pain in my stomach stop
how long ago in 2019 okay
and i had a bad bad knife pain and i
received spinal shots
from a neurologist for years two years
okay now i have nerve pain back there
and it radiates to my legs
yeah you have to you have a peripheral
neuropathy okay it's called
peripheral neuropathy okay so how much
you weigh and how old are you
i weigh 186 and i'm 73.
okay and you have some gray hair
yes do you have any spider veins or
varicose veins very severe i'm getting
uh
eight injections for those okay stop
okay because these are these have
nothing to do with age
okay this this has to do with the
nutritional deficiency and you're headed
for a ruptured aneurysm if you don't do
something about this
okay so you're 186 pounds
right correct yes okay now the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat products no
sugar
uh no carbonated drinks including the
diet ones this will be forever
then i want you to have two healthy
brain and heart patch per month to full
dose everything twice a day
down very soon okay i need you to get
two bottles a month of our msm so you
can take three of those with each meal
nine a day they will support and promote
maintain a pair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makeshift itself
and your skull all that kind of stuff
and then
um but your hair color will come back
usually within 60 to 90 days your hair
color will go back to whatever your
original color was red brown black
okay you look 40 years younger okay
and then your your varicose veins will
go away and you'll avoid those aneurysms
by doing this
okay but you also need some collagen
here
and so i do want you to yeah i want you
to take our glucogen
take five of our capsules of glucogen
twice a day as two bottles a month if
you prefer liquid you can take two
quarts a month for liquid glucogen take
an ounce twice a day
okay and it will rebuild your disc
between your vertebrae cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
i'm every two weeks
and you know give us some gauge about
how much of your hair i i take people
i don't care what race they are but if
their hair is snow white usually within
60 to 90 days it's 30 40 percent
return of the normal color within six
months they're back to their normal
color as they were when they were a
teenager
okay okay okay gotta run thank you very
very much
okay thank you thank you thumbs up
gotham thank you so
much so dr walak let's get another one
before we hit
our break karina go ahead and unmute
yourself
you are on with dr wallach kareem
dr wallach yes god bless you
god bless you many many times for what
you're doing well you're very sweet
how can we help you i organize my notes
so to be
on the point and uh not take too much
time so i'm calling this the second time
the first time i called march 17
on dead doctors don't lie radio show i'm
calling again this
one on this show so end of march my mom
will be
end of um this month my mom will be 82.
she is 132 pounds 5 foot
2. she has a history of open angle
glaucoma and cataracts
seven years ago she had two surgeries at
stanford
cataract surgeries on both sides and
glaucoma on both sides
so since probably a year or more ago
her eye vision started going bad again
uh so she goes to see the doctors every
month
and now she sees three one is cornea
the other one is i got it i got it i got
it does she have gray hair
she has gray hair okay does she have
varicose veins or spider veins
no okay does she have hemorrhoids you
know
no does she have ibs or bowel syndrome
celiac disease anything like that
um she must have something because she
can
also only uses some uh intestinal
formula in order to have a bowel
movement
okay okay
does she have any other issues how about
pressure diabetes
no she does not okay well here we go
she's gotta get rid of all the bad stuff
no fried i'm hearing a lot of buzzing or
something i don't know what that is
okay is it my budget there that's better
thank you
thank you okay yeah she needs to get rid
of all the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no gluten so we
probably noticed no sugar
no carb in our drinks including the diet
ones i wanted to have one healthy brain
and heart pack per month
i wanted to get another bottle of art
selenium one bottle of water is leaning
with five cofactors not from walgreens
but obviously with the five cofactors
uh very important here um so she'll be
able to take three of those twice a day
or two three times a day for a total of
six a day
everything else from that healthy brain
and heart packs you need to take a half
a dose twice a day
and then um i also want her to take
our msm she can get one bottle a month
and take three twice a day and this will
support there goes that noise again
okay can i go ahead and you
heard dr wallach okay thank you commuter
okay then she needs to
take the um glucogel
i want her to take um
the uh either the liquid be a half ounce
twice a day
or this the capsules you could take
three or four of those twice maybe two
bottles a month
and then because she has glaucoma i want
her to take our ultimate daily classic
tablets take three of those twice a day
two pounds a month and that will support
healthy blood pressure and healthy
pressure
in the eye but the odds are she has
osteoporosis of the skull okay i want
her to get a hold of this book it's all
in your head
okay and because i have won so many
bets from uh eye doctors okay that the p
their their patients are blind blind six
eight ten
twelve years okay they diagnosed them
not me and in 90 days they can read 20
20 without glasses
okay regardless of their age okay okay
if
that's because it was osteoporosis
squeezing this the optic nerve which is
cranial nerve number two
it's called ona optic nerve atrophy and
doctors only know three things that make
your vision go away
cataracts glaucoma and
the has to do with the macular
degeneration
of the lining of the eye and so they're
always going to pick one or two of those
and do surgery and do this and give you
medications injections because those are
the only three they know
they never talk about osteoporosis
creating ona
optic nerve atrophy and when you rebuild
the skull
that tube that the optic nerve optic
artery and optic veins are going to
open up and everything goes back to
normal i don't care if you've been blind
for 12 years
the odds are you'll be able to read 2020
without glasses
after 90 days this has been written up
and
unfortunately the doctor that i was
working with um
he was running around telling everybody
that was his idea and he went with a
bunch of bad guys to start a whole new
business we had to sue him
and so forth because he was a crook you
know typical md
all right well unfortunately there are
people out there like that dr wallach
and the nice thing about it is uh we
don't have to hang out with them
that's right we are at the top of the
hour of the ass doc
live show so we're going to take a quick
five-minute break
don't go away we will be right back with
more
questions answered by the one and only
amazing dr joel wallick
all right welcome back to the astoc live
show my name is rebecca kozak i am your
host and my amazing
co-hosts jonty mccollier nasima omar and
roseland sanchez
we are here to make sure that you're
getting the information that you need
um in regards to what dr wallach is
talking about so those of you who are
online with us you're in a special place
because you get to see
all the comments that are scrolling
through
um in this in in this zoom
um and all of the products that dr
wallach is mentioning
and how to find them so and this is how
you find
them get with the person that invited
you to
this program they have
a way to get the products for you and
make sure that you're getting the
best protocol to meet your needs
and also the best customer service
because they care about you
intimately and from the heart now for
those who
have not been sent to this program by
anybody specific
you can go to our website at
askdoclive.com
our website has all of the recordings
from all of our past
programs as well coming up on one year
this month
i can't believe it um i love it jaunty
one year and it also has a store
all the products that dr wallach is
mentioning
can be found through that store and we
also have a contact us
so if you have any questions about
products and what you should be taking
and you haven't spoken with another
distributor from youngevity or you
weren't referred to this program
specifically
feel free to use that contact us and ask
your questions
and even questions about becoming a
distributor
as well we can get answers for you there
again if somebody sent you to this
program though we want you to get back
with them okay so let's see if dr
wallach is back yet
and i am back all right so dr wallace
karina had another
question so let's see if we can get
another question in from
karina can we go ahead and unmute
yes dr wallach so to finish the story
uh she's been on your program uh what
you just mentioned
since april so for three months
and now the doctors are saying she needs
immediate surgery because she has
cornea detachment and her bl
her eye pressure is so low like three
that they need also do a second surgery
glaucoma surgery in order to raise
the pressure so what should we do and i
need to make a decision for her
well she doesn't have glaucoma for eye
pressure is low
they say severe glaucoma that was
surprising to me to say yeah they loaded
so
low by the surgery that it's now three
okay well first of all you get another
opinion go someplace else go to the eyes
eye doctors in the medical school
wherever you live there's a medical
school
in a reasonable distance find a medical
school and
take her there uh eight years old to do
eye surgery for something
now you think about this she's got
osteoporosis squeezing
her optic nerve also the optic artery
going into the eye
squeezing the vein coming back out of
the eye into the skull
and so it's affecting the pressure in
the eye
you got it it's damming up the vein
coming back from the eye
okay and damning up the artery going
into the eye
and damming up the nerve going into the
eye
by squeezing that whole
tube okay she's got osteoporosis of the
skull
and of course the first question you
need to ask her doctor
is does he have a kid in college and has
tuition due
you get in the picture here you don't do
emergency surgery
take her to another eye doctor in the in
the medical school and get another
opinion
low pressure in the eye is not glaucoma
if he's telling you that's a form of
glaucoma uh he needs to have his license
taken away
her that eye became discolored
it's it's solution even color
yeah well when you cut off the
circulation of the eye it's going to
turn color
what happens if you turn off the
circulation your hand
okay it turns a different color okay
same thing
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing that
nerve in the blood vessels
so stay on what you just told me don't
do the injury and just stay on
well stay on what i've just told you but
before you decide on the surgery go get
another opinion from the medical doctor
in the in the medical school okay
the eye doctor in medical school that'll
give you buy you some time but also
you're going to see an academic doctor
who gets paid the same no matter what
the what the diagnosis is
you got it yeah this eye doctor is
probably starving to death right now
okay medical school okay thank you so
much okay
you bet all right thank you karina thank
you dr
wallach next let's go to robert with his
hand up robert
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr wallach
dr wallach uh yes i was doing
a month ago i was doing uh too much red
meat honey and wine and i got gout
it seems to be taking a long time to go
away and what does that have to do with
my kidneys and
gut bacteria and so forth much you weigh
in how old are you
65.
okay well how much you weigh 160.
okay you've got white hair and do you
have any varicose veins or spider veins
no okay have any hemorrhoids i know it's
kind of personal but you have any
hemorrhoids
no okay i do have any bowel problems any
ibs celiac disease diverticulitis
anything like that
nothing constipation diarrhea
uh occasional constipation okay
any other issues any blood pressure
diabetes
no any respiratory stuff asthma
bronchitis copd
hiccups no okay okay no
any heart problems fast heart rate low
heart rate irregular heart rate
afib anything like that
no some thyroid issues okay
do you have anything going on in your
hands wrist
numbness tingling anything like that
no okay what about your legs numbness
tingling low back stuff
uh no have you shrunk any in height
since you were 20 years old
uh no i think i'm still the same
you're how tall five nine
okay all right so
this is uh um which i say
this is pretty simple stuff here when
you have gout
you're not able to handle the uric acid
for a variety of reasons okay
so you need to give up all the foods
that have uric acid in it
we're talking about shellfish i like
shrimp and crab and lobster and
that kind of stuff beans very rich
in that and then
you need to get get off of all the bad
stuff no fried food no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat butter in
oats
no sugar and i would urge you to get a
hold of the book let's play doctor and
it goes into gap very in great detail
and so forth tells you what foods you
know has
uric acid in it and so on let's play
doctor
and um
then i want you to take it 160 pounds
once you take two healthy brain and
heart packs per month
two healthy brain and heart pattern with
full dose everything twice a day
i also want you to take
uh our msm go ahead and take
um three of those twice as two bottles a
month
no excuse me let's just go with one
bottle a month because they're big
bottles one bottle a month it's
three twice a day the msm and they will
support promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone breaks
your bone itself
okay and then i also want you to have
our collagen and our collagen says in
big sun bursts on the label
contains no shellfish okay for
okay because we don't want people with
gaudy arthritis to skip taking the
glucago
and so we can take the capsules you
could take five of those twice a day be
two vowels a month for the capsules if
you prefer the liquid you get two quarts
a month
and um get uh
let's see here an ounce twice a day of
that
if you prefer the liquid over the
capsules and then
um there's a little bit of constipation
you have once well
it could be due to the um gluten issue
and so what you want to do is also get
and this is going to help you get rid of
the uric acid crystals and the joints
you have now
is get our herbal rain forest or herbal
rainforest it's a liquid
uh has 13 cleansing herbs and
anti-inflammatory herbs and things like
that
and 78 minerals in it so you want to
take an ounce of that twice a day as two
miles a month of our
herbal rain forest and then because you
have a thyroid issue
you need to um get our oceans gold take
three of those twice a day it's two
vowels a month and a few quid z take
three of those twice a day that's
two vowels a month um which is gold and
what else
fucoid z f u c o i d
quite z fucoid z um is made from one
ocean
and the ocean gold is made from the
other ocean okay and they
each contain eight or nine different
seaweeds and planktons and algaes and
stuff
to contain all these weird minerals in
the ocean okay
and thyroid issues whether it's
hashimoto's or just simple goiter or
whatever it is you got in the thyroid
goes away okay thyroid issues go away
very quickly
as in fact that was the first paper i
ever wrote in 1961 i was only 21 years
old
uh it was glider and feeder lambs it was
a mass die off
500 died in one night i mean they
weren't sick they're ready to go to
market two inches of wool beautiful
six-month-old lambs
farmer wakes up the next morning 500 are
dead
okay and i opened them up they all had
glider well
glider in 500 sheep you know we could
have one die
maybe three weeks later another one
would die why would 500 die in one night
because it was middle of winter in
missouri and the temperature dropped to
almost zero
and they all died of hypothermia because
the thyroid couldn't balance their body
temperature and they hold on to
hypothermia
it was my first article ever wrote so i
understand thyroid very well
okay
give us a call yeah give us a call every
couple of weeks um
robert because you're gonna have a great
story very common
uh gout is a very common issue but it's
simply
avoided do not take cortisone and
prednisone if you want pain relief you
can take our cm cream
and trauma put topically on it our
soothe and our
trauma oil soothe is from our hemp fx
cbd oil there's no thc in it so it's
legal in every state
okay and um
yeah okay ours is called um
soothe s-o-o-t-h-e and there's more bv
in it than any other
cbd oil in the market wow
okay our our hemp fx line is amazing dr
wallach i love it
and it doesn't have the thc so a lot of
instruments are great about
you know because of their employment um
you know getting tested positive or we
have we have certificates that you can
show your boss
that our stuff does not have thc in it
that's right
so awesome well dr wallach
kathy has a question and it's a very
good question
how exactly does taking vitamins open up
the opening in the head where the nerves
are being squeezed
okay especially if there's cartilage
filled the spilling space
okay what's this person's name again
kathy
kathy okay
did she give her age or anything or is
this just a general question just a
general question how exactly does taking
vitamins open up the opening in the head
where the nerves are being squeezed
okay this is very simple um there's a
disease it used to be called paget's
disease p-a-g-e-t
posterviews pages disease because dr
padgett
200 years ago was doing autopsies on
people that had all these weird things
going on
and the skull was an inch thick
the normal skull is only a quarter of an
inch thick
and when the skull is an inch thick not
only does it get bigger on the outside
but it also fills up those tunnels that
the nerves go through
okay including the spinal cord coming
out the back side well now it's called
wallex disease okay because i showed
50 years ago it was a simple nutritional
disease
okay it's called osteoporosis of the
skull when you have osteoporosis of the
skull
you lose the minerals out of your skull
and so the body tries to make up for the
difference in the loss of strength
by giving you more connective tissue so
the skull gets thicker
it used to be called pages disease now
it's called wallex disease
okay and so you can look it up
in the book it's all it's all in your
head it's one of the things
okay that's why there's 25 different
diseases you get when you get
osteoporosis called aka wallex disease
and then when you squeeze the first
cranial nerve the optic nerve
excuse me the olfactory nerve you lose
your sense of smell it's not
the coven 19 you have obviously
approaches the skull
you lose your vision okay you're
squeezing the optic nerve
cranial nerve number two okay then you
have your squeeze the fifth cranial
nerve the trigeminal nerve you get
um trigeminal neuralgia or very painful
in the face
cut off the supply of saliva and all
that kind of stuff then you get the
bell's palsy or one side of your face
groups it's the seventh cranial nerve
being squeezed you've got the
facial nerve seventh cranial nerve and
then the eighth cranial nerve has two
main branches
the auditory branch when it gets
squeezed you get ringing your ears and
and all that kind of stuff and buzzing
and tinnitus in your ears
uh when the vestibular branch of the
hvar gets squeezed you get a wallex
vertigo
okay and so um this wallex vertigo is
because that
controls balance and then the ninth
cranial nerve when it gets squeezed as a
gospel pharyngeal nerve you feel like
you always have something in your throat
all the time you keep swallowing and
swallowing you lose your sense of taste
glossopharyngeal lasso is your tongue
pharyngeal is your throat
and so anything going on with your
tongue and your throat and taste and
swallowing
that's that ninth cranial nerve being
squeezed and then
the tenth cranial nerve the vagus nerve
will make it squeeze you get uh afib
atrial fibrillation and
really a weird beating of the heart you
get tachycardia fast heart rate
bradycardia slow heart rate
um you can get what's called
gastroparesis i mean extreme
you'd rather commit suicide than have
this pain in your stomach okay called
gastroparesis
and doctor said look you must have an
ulcer we'll go ahead and take your
stomach out and take your stomach out
there's nothing wrong with your stomach
okay because it's just that um
ninth cranial nerve being squeezed
all right yeah excuse me
the 10 the 10th stream 10th grader yeah
so
and then we're giving one more one
i'm going to jump over to the spinal
cord coming out of the back of the
skulls for the big hole in the skull
called the foramen magnum which is latin
for big hole
including doctors don't realize your
spinal cord is formed in your brain not
in your spine
your final spinal cord is formed in the
brain comes out of the big hole in the
back of the skull
which is about an inch in diameter
normally but when you get osteoporosis
of the skull it goes down to a half an
inch
it's squeezing that spinal cord as it
comes out of the back of the
of the skull and you start getting
numbness and tingling your hands the
doctor says oh you have carpal tunnel
syndrome
you have trigger finger those are all
skull problems just like when you have
sciatica you have numbness and tingling
and hammer toes
and you put stuff on your feet you can't
relieve all the pain and
you can't walk that's because it's a
back thing it's sciatica
okay it's a peripheral neuropathy just
like your skull is squeezing
your spinal cord causing stuff in your
hands and your arms
okay so you take you know the healthy
brain and heart pack the msm vitamin d3
you take the glucogel
and it all goes away you get rid of 25
different diseases just by treating for
osteoporosis
of the skull and what it's doing is it's
rebuilding that bone dr wellick right
right and it shrinks it shrinks back to
from an inch thick wall expert wallex
okay disease as opposed to
padgett's disease okay wallace disease
it shrinks down to a quarter of an inch
normal size again because the ratio
of hard bone and the connective tissue
is proper
whereas when you don't have the minerals
the body tries to make up for the
lack of strength by putting in more
connective tissue and that's why it gets
so thick
and squeezes all those nerves you take
the supplements
it goes back to a normal skull and there
you go
there you go thank you so much for that
explanation dr wallach
let's go to our next hand donna donna go
ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr wallach
hi dr wallace good oh yeah how can we
help you
um uh let's listen a couple times to
your
uh challenge for the uh macular
degeneration
and
go ahead and turn your video off we're
getting a lot of
uh static feedback let's see if we can
get a stronger bandwidth for audio
uh see how do i do that i got this there
we go
all right go ahead don't try again okay
um if i heard the challenge that you had
with uh dr pugh
and i'm wondering if there's a
difference between uh macular
degeneration
wet and dry and what the protocols would
be
if there's a difference there is no
difference
okay interesting okay doctors
doctors doctors are always trying to
wheedle away to find a way to treat you
okay and so instead of just saying you
know we got to do this now we're going
to do
a b c and d instead of just a because
you got these two things we're really
just having one
okay what's the difference between
osteoporosis or the skull
your vertebrae your pelvis and your legs
nothing it's all the same doctors want
to treat those a different disease oh
you have osteoporosis skill we're going
to treat you for parkinson's disease
you understand what i'm saying so they
they give them different names
based on location location location as
opposed to just
the basic underlying disease
okay so the the brain and heart pack and
um
got to rebuild the skull stop squeezing
the optic nerve
right right
there you go and um vitamin d3 and
they're not
antioxidants like z radical or
yeah well yeah well there's selenium
you know in the in the healthy brain and
heart pack
but also um there's the cell shield rtq
um there's the btt 2.0 tablets
there's all kinds of stuff you can throw
in there finances are not a problem to
speed up the process
okay fantastic thank you okay you bet
all right now let's go to
adrian adrian go ahead and unmute
yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
hello doctor good morning hello how can
i help you
i'm 43 years old i have a gfr of 21
uh kidney disease um 222 pounds
that's what i know uh i'm on a strict
diet
you know i have to change the way i've
i've been eating and
i take a lot of supplements a lot of
kidney uh detox
cleansing uh capsules all right okay
let's go back here let's go back to your
kidneys
okay are you on dialysis yet
no okay um do you have high blood
pressure
yes you're on medication yes
do you have diabetes no okay do you have
any skin problems any eczema dermatitis
psoriasis or rosacea
do you have any heart problems afib
tachycardia bradycardia
okay uh let's see here do you have any
bowel problems constipation diarrhea
irritable
syndrome constipation is has been
recently because i've been taking the
peritoneum
powder because i have a high potassium
in my
also so how to take it
okay weight 222
okay 99.9 percent of the time when you
have kidney issues it's an artery
problem
and that goes along with the high blood
pressure because the kidney will release
a hormone called renin which drives your
blood pressure up
the kidney wants to get more blood
flowing into itself so it has a hormone
i'll renin which it releases hoping to
get more blood to come to itself okay
so it can filter the blood and do its
job it wants to earn its living
well you need to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat broth ryan
notes no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet drinks need to go
and then you need to take two of our
healthy brain and heart packs for months
two healthy brain and heart pasture
months this is going to give you 215
nutrients
215 nutrients take two of those um
a month so it can take um let's see here
um two two full doses a day
uh okay uh 221 pounds
two full doses a day and then i also
want you to take our msm
take three of those three times a day
that's for the walls of the arteries as
well as
um uh your cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue that
kind of stuff um then i want you to take
three of those uh your in your case once
you take three three times a day so you
want two bottles of the msm
so you can take three three times a day
and then i want you to take the vitamin
d3 take three of those twice it has two
bowels a month
and then again i want you to take the
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those three times a day that's
three bottles a month and they will
support the healthy blood pressure
as well as blood flow through the
blocked arteries including the kidneys
now the blockages in the arteries will
slowly go away as long as you do it
exactly as i told you and the
you cannot be in any statin drugs or
anything like that
so i'm i am on a simvastatin for
cholesterol yeah
yeah well you should not be on that okay
because
um uh cholesterol doesn't cause
blockages of the arteries
75 of your brain weight is cholesterol
of testosterone is cholesterol and so
you don't want trouble in your brain you
don't want trouble and your testosterone
okay
and so you have you have to be eating
three eggs twice a day
and if you have any of the standard
drugs left over don't throw it away it's
expensive
what you want to do is box it up with a
nice ribbon and give it to your doctor
with love just like double07
giving stuff to russia with love okay
give it to him
or her okay and then for the
constipation
i want you to take um let's see here
uh the constipation i want you to take
uh two doses a day that'd be two quarts
a month
of our herbal rainforest has 13
cleansing herbs
okay it'll help speed up cleaning up the
arteries and it has 78 minerals in it
and it's as the name implies uh herbal
rainforest
uh and um has the
the 13 cleansing herbs and the 78
minerals
that will deal with the constipation
issue but more importantly it'll deal
with getting rid of
all the toxic stuff out of your body
okay
and including helping you speed up the
reversal of the um plaque in your
arteries
okay including the ones in the kidneys
so i have people who have not urinated
in 10 years they're on dialysis six days
a week they were on dialysis for 25
years because they never wanted to get a
kidney transplant
which is two weeks on the program i just
gave you they're urinating again
after 10 years they're not urinating so
they drop them from six days a week to
three days a week
and two more weeks you're totally off
the dialysis after 25 years of being on
dialysis
so i do this thousands of times a month
all over the world this is very simple
and so please do call us on a regular
basis particularly when you go to your
doctor
and see what your doctor says okay
but don't forget those ultimate daily
classic tablets because you want that
blood pressure to come down again don't
cold turkey off the medication but as
the blood pressure drops
you can slowly reduce the medication
based on the numbers right
right and then call us every couple of
weeks and call us anytime you go to the
doctor you get another re-evaluation
because he's going to be freaked out
all the supplements doctor that i have
had i actually have like three or four
different supplements that i bought
one for the blood pressure one for detox
do i
don't take those no more well do they
work for you
well i i started them a couple you know
some a couple of months ago some a
couple weeks ago
well if they haven't worked by now
they're not going to work so when you
get ours
just replace theirs with ours okay
because you know just taking stuff and
you're still you know
not getting the job done after a couple
of weeks or a couple of months there's
something wrong
okay yeah it's actually been uh
declining in the next last couple years
uh gfr has so yeah
yeah the glomerular filtration rate yes
okay so give us a call on a regular
basis you're going to have a great
testimony
your story will save a lot of people a
lot of misery and add 25 to 50 healthful
years of life okay
perfect i appreciate it okay okay adrian
thank you so much bye-bye
now something i want to point out dr
wallach
nutrients need cofactors to be able to
be absorbed by the body
it's like helpers and if you're just
taking
one nutrient from here and you're not
getting the
cofactors you're not going to be
realizing the results
that's correct that's something when i
um because i used to be a cherry picker
and had no results and kept going
downhill and downhill
and when i saw the ingredients
in the youngevity products and i was
looking up
how nutrients interacted with each other
and how
they actually synergistically work
together dr wallach
funny how that works it it's it's
incredible
and it's a really good thing for all of
us
because when you can take supplements
all day long but if they're not working
together
and in a form that your body can use
you're not going to reap the benefits
you hear you hit the nail on the head
rebecca this is why i don't tell people
people i say well
what mineral is it doc well i used to
tell people
30 40 years ago what it was and they'd
run to the grocery store and buy that
one mineral and then three months later
they were dead
they said hey ruthie whatever happened
to your husband well he did what you
said he took that nutrient and he died
and so i stopped telling people what
that nutrient is because people will
cherry pick
and why would i want to spend 25 bucks
for everything
when i can just spend five dollars for
one
and then you die okay and so i stopped
telling people what that one nutrient is
because you and that's why we put these
five cofactors in our selenium
because selenium won't work without
those other five cofactors
just like calcium doesn't do a good job
without the vitamin d3
the magnesium okay
and so um this is this is why we do the
things we do
and this is why we went from 90
essential nutrients in the healthy start
pack to the 215 nutrients in the healthy
brain and heart pack
and the of course the healthy start pack
is the core
of the healthy brain and heart pack it's
still there it's in it's the core
and then we've added these other 115
nutrients to it
and then you know you get these ads on
tv
from these vitamin mineral companies
they say complete nutrition
complete nutrition 27 nutrients well
it's not even a third
of the original 90 and it's not even 10
of the 215.
no it's not and and the
same holds true also dr wallick for iv
therapies when they're given an iv with
just a single nutrient
that is correct is that true yeah oh
yeah absolutely
and so uh you know when when you go to
the doctor you know once a month to get
an iron shot
really the doctor just wants that
hundred bucks the office call
from the insurance company because it's
a silly
way to approach something because the
iron is not the only thing you're not
absorbing
okay because when your intestines are
dead
why do you have to get an iron shot well
you're anemic well i've been you know
supplementing with iron doc you gave me
a prescription to go to the pharmacy and
i got the iron but i've been taking that
for six months i'm getting worse my
anemia is getting worse
that's because they've been eating
gluten their intestines are dead and
they can't absorb the iron so you got to
come in
now once a week or once a month and get
an iron shot
and so you got to get off the gluten
take the 90 essential nutrients and
that's why we've we went back and made
the btt 2.5
because we added the methyl folate so
now we have 400 times the amount of
folic acid in there that we used to have
we had you know an optimal amount of
folic acid but if you're not absorbing
it
you know we want to give you more but
also if you're anemic
for any reason not only do you want iron
and b12 and copper and
and amino acids sulfur but you also need
oh yeah
folate and so we're kind of hedging
everybody's bed here by putting more of
these things in there
to make sure that you're going to get
the job done so you don't have to go get
a
bone marrow transplant because you have
bone marrow dysplasia your bone marrow
is completely replaced by scar tissue
and it's not functional anymore
that's why these people die from covet
because they cannot respond to the
vaccination vaccinations don't kill
viruses they just re you know alert the
body to the bad dna and rna
and when the bug comes along if you
can't release
white blood cells antibodies red blood
cells and platelets go killing eat the
viruses
well guess what uh you're dead
right so but i was vaccinated god why am
i here
so so with this um beyond tanki
tangerine 2.5
and having the methylated folate in
there
there are people with conditions called
mthfr
that have a hard time taking nutrients
because they
they just don't interact with their
bodies well and with this methylated
folate
it's in a form that they can actually
absorb
well not only that within the body
they've got to get off of gluten
so when they have these things gluten
alert gluten alert gluten alert gluten
alert
absolutely you've got you've got to give
your bodies a fighting chance by
eliminating
gluten i mean it's inflammatory it coats
the intestines
it prevents absorption and causes leaky
gut i mean there's so many different
different things that it does and even
if you don't think
that you have a gluten intolerance give
it 21 days folks
i've had so many clients say well i
don't have a gluten intolerance i said
okay let's give it 21 days and let me
just
let's just check back and see how you're
feeling
and they're like oh my word
i can't i can't believe how much more
energy
i have how my bloating went down
all these different things that they
didn't think
were affecting them and they realized
the benefits
after removing just that single
protein from the diet it's it's fabulous
but
you have to make the choice and it is a
choice
empower yourself to make these choices
i mean we were bombarded by
so many things out in the market and the
convenience of them
that you gotta really take a look at it
look at the labels and think does my
body need this
is this gonna benefit my body what would
be a better option
i love it when people say well my doctor
says
i can get everything i need just by
eating well well that doctor should have
his license taken away from him
okay because he just knows yeah
[Laughter]
you cannot get everything you need just
by eating well because plants only need
three elements from soil and you need
60.
that's right that's right
let's go to the next hand dr walik okay
okay dear let's do it
we have aina aina go ahead and uh on
mute yourself
you were on live with dr wallach hey
unmute yourself sweetheart go ahead i
sent a request
just click yes
try again
i am i need it now there you go now you
are
okay um uh
i'm um 83 5 foot 2 and 100 pounds
and i've just been i'm excited i was
gonna go 150 years with you dr wallach
good girl let's do it yeah i know but
now they say i
have a irregular heartbeat and i've
i've been doing the heart and brain pack
for a few months
and the
msm what should i do now what what's
your okay
okay now this now there's a regular
heartbeat are they calling it afib
yeah okay yes but he said it was it was
not yeah yeah they did i think he did
put that word in
okay now do you have you have some white
hair do you have any varicose veins in
your legs
i have on one leg and it's once it
seemed to go away
but it doesn't now it's just a little
bit okay are you from germany are you
from are you from germany originally
no denmark oh denmark okay i was getting
a little bit of mid-european accent
there okay good thank you
sorry no no no don't apologize i think
it's very beautiful
okay now also um let's see here
uh do you have any skin issues any
eczema dermatitis or psoriasis
no okay do you have any bowel issues any
irritable bowel syndrome
constipation diarrhea anything like that
okay good and you have a pressure
diabetes
no diabetes i think my blood pressure it
really fluctuates
okay but i'm i'm on all your diets and
everything
okay good all right so here we go when
you have a fib
okay this is the tenth cranial nerve the
vagus nerve being squeezed or it could
also mean
it could also mean that you're shrinking
how do you say you say you're five
two um were you five four one time in
your life
no i was like five two and and a half to
two and three quarters
sort of okay so maybe we'll also maybe a
little bit maybe a half inch okay
um because sometimes um when the first
um
um four discs in your
back um shrink the
first four um thoracic nerves get
squeezed by the
vertebrae getting closer together and
they can also cause an irregular
heartbeat called a-fib
so here we go thank you okay really
really work on getting rid of all the
bad stuff everybody in your household
dog cat bird fish renter
grandkids spouse everybody caregiver has
to be drop dead gluten free
no fried foods no no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat broth around
notes no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet one's got to go
and 100 pounds i want you to have one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
and you get another another bottle of
our selenium so you can take three of
those twice a day one bottle of slime
comes with it
not our walgreens leaning but arsene
with the five cofactors
okay then i also want you to take our
msm one bottle of mustard take three of
those twice a day or two three times a
day six a day
they will support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
including in the skull
including in the skull now do you have
any ring in your ears or tinnitus
anything like that no no okay do you
have any balance problems or
very slightly okay uh i don't know
maybe a little bit okay a little bit all
right so yeah
that kind of stuff will go away and um
do you have any vision issues are you
sort of your vision kind of gets a
little worse because a little better
gets a little worse because
anything like that no it's pretty steady
okay what about your sense of smell have
you lost your sense of smell
no okay but nothing going on your hands
or fingers or wrists your arms or
shoulders
i've been absolutely a hundred percent
up till this sort of happened
okay good okay here we go so again
at 100 pounds that one healthy brain and
heart pack get that extra sleep so you
can take three of those twice a day or
two three times a day for total six a
day
and i want you to take take our um
uh let's see here vitamin d3 take three
of those twice he has two bottles a
month
then if you prefer the liquids you can
take our
cal toddy take a half ounce of that at
breakfast half ounce of dinner time it's
a liquid comes in quartz
if you prefer capsules you can take our
glucogel
capsules take three or four of those
twice a day that'll be one bottom one
because it's a big bottle
okay and then also i want you to
uh take the uh ultimate daily classic
tablets
ultimate daily classic tablets i take
three of those twice a day that's two
bottles a month that's going to help you
with this blood pressure that kind of
wanders around all over the place
and it'll help speed up the hair color
coming back
to normal and also your varicose veins
going away
oh and also the afib will go away afib
is squeezing of the tenth cranial nerve
okay are the spot first four spinal
nerves okay either way
or both so all that's going to go away
with this little program we gave you
um don't submit any surgery do not let
them do any ablation
did they talk to you about ablation not
yet
okay good don't let them don't let them
talk into that one because they kill
more people that
they anesthetize you they cut you open
and put a branding on your heart trying
to stop it from jumping around
and they kill people with that procedure
ablation so don't don't volunteer for
that one
okay and then give us a call every
couple of weeks or anytime you go to the
doctor because you're going to have
a good experience and people are going
to say well
are you dyeing your hair are you dyeing
your hair no
you're 83 years old and you have hair
color like a 30 year old okay
that's because your hair color well your
hair color will come back your original
hair color will come back
your varicose veins will go away and
your your afib will go away
okay because it's all due to nutritional
deficiencies
but dr dr wallach mm-hmm i spent he
wants to eat one
one gluten bread have it in a plastic
bag
no gluten bread no no there are the only
gluten non-gluten bread is rice bread
yes i i have i i that's all i do
so no gluten no gluten no gluten
so if you can have rice crackers rice
cakes so i said
out the door
[Laughter]
okay thank you so much you're very proud
of you thank you
okay okay bye-bye all right thank you
aina
next road to robert
robert go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallace yeah can
you hear me
yes sir i uh yes hi dr wallach um
i uh i have meniere's disease very badly
in my uh
my right ear so uh it's uh driving me
crazy
okay how old are you 50.
and how much you weigh uh 190.
okay and let's see do you have any other
issues how about pressure diabetes
no okay do you have any uh
balance problems yes uh
dizziness and uh uh hearing loss
oh okay do you ever have any um
tinnitus or ringing or whooshing in the
ears or anything like that
oh yeah yeah i have a lot of that too
okay i cannot see you do you have gray
hair white hair
i have um well it's a mix of gray and
brown
we call it salt and pepper yeah but it's
shaved off too so
i keep it short yeah okay so do you have
anything varicose veins or hemorrhoids
or anything like that
no okay any bowel any bowel problems
ibs or bowel syndrome celiac disease
diverticulitis crohn's disease anything
like that
no okay well here we go get your pen and
paper out
um yeah yeah you have osteoporosis of
the skull what's going on here
okay uh squeezing yeah yeah
squeezing the vestibular branch to the
eighth cranial nerve
okay so you need to get rid of all the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
meats oils no gluten so we brought
around us no sugar
no carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go and then
at um let's see here uh you said you
weighed 190 pounds i want you to take
a two of the healthy brain heart packs
for a month to full dose everything
twice a day
once you get two bottles a month of our
msm so you can take three of those with
each meal there's nine a day
it will support promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone brakes bone itself
including the skull and then i want you
to take vitamin d three three of those
twice is
two bowels a month and then i want you
to take our glucogel you can take the
liquid if you want
uh to be two quarts a month for you an
ounce twice a day or if you prefer the
capsules you can take
two bottles a month that's five of the
capsules twice a day of the glucogel
if you choose the capsules and then one
more thing i want you to throw in
the um a few quite see take three of
those twice today it's an
anti-inflammatory
from seaweed okay from the ocean from
eight or nine different seaweeds
and then i also um let's see here
i think that's gonna cover it yeah
that's gonna cover it
um and so uh you're gonna have a great
story so if you would call us every
couple of weeks
and give us a you know a status report
anytime you go to the doctor
and get a status report from the doctor
because they're going to be shocked
your progress this is all going to go
away because these are just simple
nutritional deficiency diseases
okay okay thank you very much
okay robert yep they have nothing to do
with aging it's all nutritional
here including including the hair color
thing that'll you'll look like you're 25
years old again
all right wow that's amazing thank you
very much
thank you bye-bye all right thank you
robert
so next let's go to evan
with her hand up yvonne go ahead and
unmute yourself you are live with dr
wallach
hi ron
trying oh there you go
good morning doc good to see you again
um i
have a gen i have a lady 50 years old
and she has been uh diagnosed with
um adrenal exhaustion she also has
um um um
sorry uh low blood pressure
and uh she is 56 about
150 pounds
okay no highlight pressure no diamond
she got low blood pressure no
diabetes no arthritis
you're muted again yvonne
i'm not sure there you go there you go
don't touch anything go ahead
okay does she have any gray hair
uh slightly
she's kind of like slightly being
pregnant okay yep okay
does she have any varicose veins or
spider veins or legs or ankles or feet
uh some okay
any uh any diabetes no
okay all right so she's getting rid of
all the bad stuff no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat products no sugar no carbohydrate
drinks even the diet one's got to go
she needs to be taking two of our
healthy brain and heart packs per month
to full dose everything twice a day
she needs to take um uh let's see here
in her case here
uh okay let's just go with one bottle a
month of the msm so you can take three
of those twice a day
that will support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes bone cells
her hair color will start to come back
also and for the adrenal exhaustion
i want her to be sure to eat three eggs
twice a day with soft yolks hard-boiled
eggs won't count and
fried eggs cause cancer so softball soft
yolk so poached soft yolk soft
scrambling butter i also wanted her to
have
our hgh or hgh i wanted to take five of
those
twice a day as a big bottle you can do
that with one bottle a month
hgh and and that is the food for the
um um pituitary gland which controls all
the other glands including the adrenal
glands
okay and so the hdh5 those twice a day
one bottle a month
and then i think that will cover it
give us a call every couple of weeks um
oh she also needs one more thing the
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those twice a day
that will help normalize blood pressure
and support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries
and veins even the spider veins their
legs and all that kind of stuff but the
hair color will come back
within 60 to 90 days she's gonna look
like she's
um 25 years old again okay thank you doc
hey
i um ended up having her start with the
de-stress for the adrenals was that the
well she can she can take that that's
fine de-stress is fine
she can take three of those twice a day
um absolutely
that's it was a good choice but that's
you don't want to cherry-pick one
product she needs a complete program so
just keep her taking that but
but add this to it she is on a starter
pack but then we added the de-stress
so would i change that to the hgh and
the ultimate classic
well i want the i want the i want the
selenium
so that's why she's got to go to the
healthy brain and heart pack because i
wanted to take the selenium
three twice a day okay
because she needs she needs several
things here okay include
but i don't want to say what they are
because i don't want to run to the store
and buy that one thing
all right okay thank you so much you bet
thank you keith you know call us every
couple weeks let us know how she's doing
will do uh also just a quick report i
had one of the gentlemen that
you helped assist with uh urinating um
this will be a probably about my fifth
one that we've helped and
going from about a tablespoon to over a
cup
uh urinating over cup in um probably
45 to 60 days oh beautiful we're going
the right direction
yes thanks for the report you bet thank
you keep up the good work
awesome awesome i love that i love that
so you know if you've got some health
challenges going
on i love this quote
um by basketball coach jerry dunn
don't limit your challenges challenge
your limits and i love the fact
that if we're given a limit we don't
have to accept that
lemon especially when it comes to health
that we have so much
amazing absorbable supplementation
with the youngevity products that dr
wallach was so
instrumental in bringing to us that
you know we challenge those limits and
we no longer have those limits
and i love that dr wallach thank you so
so much for all that you've done for
almost 80 years now because well thank
you you have 74.
almost 80 yeah but thank you so much
for assembling the team you have and
putting things together
we really appreciate all you guys do um
and of course i'm going to be on with
george nori here
you know the father of this segment here
um the 13th uh 10 to 12
p.m pacific time i'm glad when i'm on
the west coast and i do when i'm on the
east coast is one to three in the
morning
[Laughter]
yeah that you know the the call team
they're they're dedicated dr
wallach yeah they are dedicated so
well that's fabulous um we are coming up
to the top of the hour
it looks like we actually got through
all the hands today so
i'm excited about that i always feel
guilty when we have to leave with the
hands still up um but i want to remind
everybody that this program is brought
to you by askdoclive.com and i have to
thank
mz zuerling for for putting this
together for jonty mccollier for being
the
technical guru behind making sure
everything it goes smoothly he's got the
website askdoc
live and he's putting all
of the replays from our programs
on askdoc live and then he's like on
top of it he's got it down pat he's
absolutely amazing i love him
and also the store and the contact us
and the valuable information that can be
found
at the askdoclive.com website
we have a newsletter that you can
subscribe to also
and i i encourage you you know
get involved knowledge
is something that can't be taken away
from you but without
knowledge you're not gonna know what
you can do to empower yourself to
make lasting and impactful changes
within your life within your health and
all of those around you
again get back with the person that
invited you to this
program they have a vested
interest in making sure and that's
coming from the heart
making sure that you're getting what you
okay you can also use the contact
us option at our website
askdoclive.com and reach out with your
questions
in regards to to products and protocols
you should be taking
we have some certified holistic health
coaches that are there
to help answer those questions for you
now on behalf of myself i know we're a
couple minutes early
actually i had one one thing and we
covered it just a little bit dr wallach
trigger finger you had mentioned it as
we were going through
you know how supplementation can correct
the thickness of the skull but this
individual is wanting to know if trigger
finger
can can go away yes trigger fingers
no no trigger finger and hammer chose
the same disease
okay this is caused by a peripheral
neuropathy
um a hammer toe is caused by sciatica
squeezing the nerves to go down the legs
you know from the back when you have
trigger finger it's the skull squeezing
the spinal cord
so it's one of those 25 diseases
of the skull when you have osteoporosis
of the skull
you deal with the osteoporosis of the
skull get rid of all the bad stuff
take the 90 essential nutrients with a
particular emphasis
on the msm vitamin d3 the glucogel
and again the
215 nutrients and trigger finger
and hammer toe
um carpal tunnel syndrome arthritis of
the fingers
arms shoulders neck it all goes away
this goes away none of it is autoimmune
none of it is a genetic
we have five generations in the family
with trigger finger
well either they were bank robbers or
they don't have osteoporosis in the
skull
oh i love your humor and and i'm a
testament i mean i had carpal tunnel
looking at surgery dr wallach
and i got on the supplement program i
have a serious
pain would you look at that
no pain i mean before doing this
was like taking a knife and now you
bring tears your eyes yeah
yeah now i do it with no problem and i i
love not having physical limitations
well that's why we all love you we can't
thank you enough for your guidance and
leadership
and um making sure everything happens
right and same with john t
and ruth ellen and um
okay so we can't thank everybody enough
and uh this is a great particular show
and i'm glad we got that
quantitative numbers out there 150
million tons a year
of sediment backing up behind the dam
dams it's not
carb it's not fossil fuels it's causing
the carbon dioxide to go up it's the
damn dams
okay and so um that's going to be the
title of my next cd dvd and book
is the damn dams because now we've got
it quantified i mean that was scary when
i saw
that i mean holy moly i knew it was bad
but i didn't realize it was that bad 150
million tons a year just in the usa
alone
yeah that is that is absolutely it's
breathtaking
and this is this is documented this
isn't a guesswork this is well
documented lsu
like 11 million dollar grant okay from
the government
this was a big big study and they just
brought it out just a couple of days ago
the results of the study i've been
yelling about it for 50 years
it's yeah it's it's cause and effect dr
wallach i mean you're gonna have
consequences when you now when you mess
up the natural order of things
well duh and and that's what we're
experiencing now
well i know dove but you know some
people it's like come on let's think
about this
i mean there's benefits that we've that
we've you know gotten from
you know electricity and all that stuff
and one of those dams that you had
mentioned earlier in the show i live
less than 20 miles from um
it makes for a great backdrop on you
know fourth of july
but it's
you know it really gives you something
to think about well
that's why there's brakes on that's why
there's brakes on cars
okay they put the brakes on the car so
you don't have to drag your foot to slow
it down
the same way nothing wrong with
electricity
but we have to fix the problem that was
created by
damming up the rivers and cutting off
the food supply to the ocean
that's that's it but you know in the
meantime since that's not something
that's like
um an easy fix we have
supplementation supplementation that the
body can
actually utilize even if you think they
fix it
and they start letting some of that silk
go through i would still take my 90
essential nutrients
oh absolutely i won't go a day without
them
no way there's no way i'm going
backwards now it's onwards i'm hitting
120 just leaving and we're gonna go go
go
so all right looks like somebody came
unmuted here
well going to come up with a series of
um headstones for graves
that they all say the same thing then
you put the person's name underneath it
and this thing is going to be on this
gravestone
is my doctor said
i'm on mine hitting 120 mine's gonna be
thanks to my doctor yeah
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna list you on
my
on my headstone he treated me like a dog
but it got better
yes yes and uh you've learned to love me
and i appreciate that and i appreciate
your patience
okay everybody thank you so much for
joining us for the askdoc
live show we love you we appreciate you
be empowered challenge
don't accept tags challenge that
and empower yourself to look into other
options and supplementation folks with
over 600 diseases being caused
by nutrient deficiencies let's think
about that correct the nutritional
deficiencies
and what is your body going to be able
to do
we don't heal it but your body's
designed to do some amazing
things so support it
love it it is worth it it's
i mean the investment that you put into
your body today is going to save
money in the future add 25 to 50 healthy
years your life
exactly exactly and less wrinkles and
all that good stuff so everybody have a
fabulous fabulous day thank you again dr
wallach for joining us for this two
hours
we love you we appreciate you and we
will see you next friday
god bless doclive.com god bless you
happy fourth of july everyone yes have a
great fourth be safe
and hydrate hydrate
bye for now